We've all heard of workplace burnout, the physical and emotional exhaustion that workers feel when they're overwhelmed with too many deadlines, too many tasks, or too many hours on the job. But for some employees, too much work isn't the problem. Instead of burnout, they're suffering from Borout, chronic boredom that leaves them feeling disengaged, unfulfilled, and frustrated with their jobs. While Borout might not get as much attention as burnout, researchers say that its effects can be just as damaging. Today we're going to talk with two psychologists who study chronic workplace boredom about why it happens and what individuals and employers can do to combat it. So how common is chronic boredom at work? How does it affect workers' mental health and their job performance?
我们都听说过职场倦怠（burnout），即员工在面对过多的截止日期、过多的任务或过长的工作时间而感到不知所措时，所产生的身心俱疲。但对一些员工来说，问题不在于工作太多。他们遭受的不是倦怠，而是“无聊症”（boreout），这是一种长期的无聊感，让他们感到与工作脱节、无法实现自我，并对工作感到沮丧。虽然“无聊症”可能不像“倦怠”那样受到关注，但研究人员表示，其影响可能同样具有破坏性。今天，我们将与两位研究长期职场无聊感的心理学家探讨这种现象发生的原因，以及个人和雇主可以采取哪些措施来应对。那么，职场中的长期无聊感有多普遍？它如何影响员工的心理健康和工作表现？
How can bosses and organizations recognize it in their employees? How does Borough look different in different types of work and at different career stages? And how can companies design jobs better to make the work as engaging as possible. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today.
老板和组织如何识别员工身上的这种现象？“无聊症”在不同类型的工作和不同的职业阶段表现有何不同？公司又该如何更好地设计工作，使工作尽可能地引人入胜？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们有两位嘉宾。
First is Dr. Lada Harjou, an associate professor at the EM Lyon Business School in Lyon, France, where she studies employee well-being and mental health at work. She holds a PhD in work and organizational psychology. Her research on chronic workplace boredom has looked at topics, including how boredom affects workers' health and the relationship between boreout and burnout. Next is Dr. Sharon Parker, who is the John Curtin Distinguished Professor in Organizational Behavior at Curtin University in Perth, Australia, where she founded and leads the Center for Transformative Work Design. She's a world-leading
第一位是拉达·哈乔（Lada Harjou）博士，她是法国里昂EM里昂商学院的副教授，在那里她研究员工的幸福感和职场心理健康。她拥有工作与组织心理学博士学位。她对长期职场无聊感的研究涵盖了多个主题，包括无聊感如何影响员工健康，以及“无聊症”与“倦怠”之间的关系。接下来是莎伦·帕克（Sharon Parker）博士，她是澳大利亚珀斯科廷大学组织行为学的约翰·柯廷杰出教授，在那里她创立并领导了变革性工作设计中心。她是世界领先的
research in work design and has published more than 150 journal articles on topics, including performance, proactivity, employee mental health, and organizational change. Dr. Parker is a fellow of the Academy of Management, the Australian Academy of Social Sciences, and the Society for Industrial and Organizational Psychology. Dr. Harjou, Dr. Parker, thank you for joining me today. It's a pleasure. It's a pleasure to be here. Well, let's start with the big picture and try to expand on the brief description I gave in the
工作设计领域的研究者，已发表了150多篇期刊文章，主题包括绩效、主动性、员工心理健康和组织变革。帕克博士是管理学会、澳大利亚社会科学院以及工业与组织心理学会的院士。哈乔博士、帕克博士，感谢你们今天加入我的节目。这是我的荣幸。很高兴能来到这里。那么，让我们从大局出发，试着扩展一下我在介绍中给出的简短描述。
introduction. What is bore out? And I know it goes by a few names, including chronic boredom, and rust out. What do you each call it and how do you define it in your work? Boredom or boreout. I myself call it boredom. There are different types of boredom. I believe that all of us have experience of it. It can be long-lasting. It can pass quickly once we read ourselves of whatever it is that's boring. Or it can be a more persistent chronic type of of boredom, which doesn't pass or at least not as quickly as a shorter type of boredom.
什么是“无聊症”？我知道它有几个名字，包括长期无聊和“生锈症”（rust out）。你们各自怎么称呼它，在工作中又是如何定义的？无聊或无聊症。我自己称之为无聊。无聊有不同的类型。我相信我们所有人都经历过。它可以是长期的。一旦我们摆脱了那些令人无聊的事情，它可能很快就会过去。或者它可能是一种更持久的慢性无聊，不会消失，或者至少不会像短期的无聊那样快地消失。
Right. So it's not an everyday thing. I mean, we can all expect to be bored from time to time at our jobs, but this is much more chronic, is that right? Yes, so it's very normal to be bored every now and then, even though we so dislike boredom. I find in our culture at least, we are kind of allergic to feeling bored, try to avoid it. But it's very normal. It's a lot. It's not dangerous as such, but it's very different to experience boredom most, if not all of the time when at workplace. So that's a different type of situation then. Dr. Parker, let me ask you, how is boredom related to burnout? So if you're bored, are you more likely to experience burnout as well? No, they're quite, they're different things. So,
对。所以这不是日常琐事。我的意思是，我们都预料到在工作中会时不时感到无聊，但这更像是长期的，对吗？是的，偶尔感到无聊是非常正常的，尽管我们非常讨厌无聊。我发现至少在我们的文化中，我们对感到无聊有一种过敏反应，试图避免它。但这很正常。这没什么。它本身并不危险，但如果你在工作场所大部分时间（如果不是全部时间）都感到无聊，那体验就完全不同了。所以那是一种不同的情况。帕克博士，请问，无聊与倦怠有何关联？如果你感到无聊，你是否也更容易经历倦怠？不，它们是完全不同的事情。所以，
you know, in a sense, burnout is usually a state that you experience. of exhaustion, cynicism, and feeling that you're not really getting anywhere. And it comes typically from excessive workload, too much to do, demands that are overwhelming and so on. Again, tends to be a fairly chronic situation. Whereas bore out really is there multiple causes, but one of them is not having enough to do or not at least having enough challenging, interesting, meaningful work to do. So they're quite different. I think they can have those feelings of cynicism in common.
你知道，从某种意义上说，倦怠通常是你经历的一种状态。精疲力竭、愤世嫉俗，并感觉自己真的毫无进展。它通常源于过重的工作量、太多的事情要做、令人不知所措的要求等等。同样，这往往是一种相当长期的状况。而“无聊症”确实有多种原因，但其中之一是事情做得不够，或者至少没有足够具有挑战性、有趣、有意义的工作可做。所以它们非常不同。我认为它们可能都有那种愤世嫉俗的感觉。
And I believe there is some research that shows that people who are chronically bored can also feel exhausted. It's because, you know, I think if you're really bored and checked out with your work and it's meaningless, but you've got to keep on going, you know, then that sort of just wears you down and makes you cynical and exhausted. So different things, but they can connect and you can experience them sometimes at the same time. How common is actual boreout? I mean, the real syndrome that we're talking about, not just regular everyday boredom.
我相信有一些研究表明，长期感到无聊的人也会感到精疲力竭。这是因为，你知道，我认为如果你真的对工作感到无聊和心不在焉，而且工作毫无意义，但你又必须坚持下去，你知道，那就会让你感到疲惫，让你变得愤世嫉俗和精疲力竭。所以它们是不同的事情，但它们可以相互关联，有时你可能会同时经历它们。实际的“无聊症”有多普遍？我是说，我们谈论的真正的综合征，而不仅仅是普通的日常无聊。
How common is it? Do we have any data on this? Yeah, I mean, the kind of prevalence of boreout at workplaces is, is underestimated because, well, for the same reason, then probably burnout is underestimated among workforce because we tend to assess these things with questionnaires and then people who are maybe suffering of this phenomenon the most are not the most likely to answer these questionnaires. So it's most likely also underdiagnosed.
它有多普遍？我们有这方面的数据吗？是的，我的意思是，职场中“无聊症”的流行程度被低估了，因为，好吧，原因和倦怠在劳动力中可能被低估的原因一样，因为我们倾向于用问卷来评估这些事情，而那些可能最受这种现象困扰的人，往往不是最有可能回答这些问卷的人。所以它很可能也被漏诊了。
at workplaces. So it's probably more common than what we can actually grasp in our surveys. But we have tried. I mean, so for example, we published a study some years ago where we looked at prevalence of boredom in its different frequencies, you know, how often do people experience boredom versus how often they experience burnout seem to. terms, namely exhaustion. We had different samples. We had a big sample of Finnish employees, and then we had another sample of employees in the UK. And in both of these samples, we found that actually there was a large proportion of workers in our data who reported experiencing boredom very often. And this was a large perversion. And these were the employees who also reported
在工作场所。所以它可能比我们在调查中实际掌握的情况更普遍。但我们已经尝试过了。我的意思是，例如，我们几年前发表了一项研究，我们观察了不同频率的无聊的流行程度，你知道，人们经历无聊的频率与他们经历倦怠（即精疲力竭）的频率相比如何。我们有不同的样本。我们有一个庞大的芬兰员工样本，然后我们还有另一个英国员工样本。在这两个样本中，我们发现实际上我们的数据中有很大一部分员工报告说经常感到无聊。这是一个很大的比例。而这些员工也报告了
than exhaustion, so burnout symptoms, almost equally as often. So indeed, as Dr. Parker mentioned earlier, these phenomena, they can go, if not hand in hand, at least people can experience them simultaneously. And yes, it is probably more common than what we think, because indeed, as also was just mentioned, we kind of think about boredom as something that, a result of not having enough things to do. And it's not that many workplaces that where this actually is the situation. I mean, some workers would like to have more to do than what they actually have. But I mean, this is maybe not as common. But it's indeed not the only reason for why people are
精疲力竭，也就是倦怠症状，频率几乎一样高。所以确实，正如帕克博士之前提到的，这些现象，如果不是齐头并进，至少人们可以同时经历它们。是的，它可能比我们想象的更普遍，因为确实，正如刚才提到的，我们倾向于认为无聊是事情做得不够的结果。而实际上并非很多工作场所都是这种情况。我的意思是，有些员工希望做的事情比他们实际做的要多。但我的意思是，这可能不是最常见的原因。但这确实不是人们感到
bored, but because we so strongly associate a boredom with not having things to do, we kind of think that it cannot be that common or it cannot happen in certain types of work. And this is not the case. Dr. Parker, you're nodding your head. So all that jibes with what you see in the research as well. Yeah, I'm not sure if it's your study, Dr. Hajjou, but one I'm aware of is a finished study that looked at sort of combinations of exhaustion and boredom.
无聊的唯一原因，但因为我们将无聊与没有事情做联系得太紧密，我们倾向于认为它不可能那么普遍，或者它不可能发生在某些类型的工作中。但事实并非如此。帕克博士，你在点头。所以这一切也与你在研究中看到的情况相符。是的，我不确定这是否是你的研究，哈乔博士，但我知道的一项芬兰研究观察了精疲力竭和无聊的组合。
and there's about 7% of the people in this sample were bored and exhausted, so it's a fairly small number, but there were about 20% of people that were somewhat bored and exhausted. So if you put those two numbers together, that's about 27% that are saying that they are bored with some degree of feeling exhausted as well. And so that's about a third actually, which is quite a high number. again, I think we tend to think that boredom or bore out is something that's typical, you know, in certain sorts of jobs. But in fact, it can happen in all jobs, can happen in professional jobs even, where you might be doing things that look on the surface quite challenging and interesting, like law, for example, but you might just be bored because you've done it for 15, 20 years and it's not stretching you and challenging you and you're not growing anymore. You know, so it's something that can, I guess, happen in any occupation, at any age, you know, in any sort of role, really.
在这个样本中，大约有7%的人感到无聊且精疲力竭，所以这是一个相当小的数字，但大约有20%的人感到有些无聊且精疲力竭。所以如果你把这两个数字加在一起，大约有27%的人说他们感到无聊，同时也伴随着某种程度的精疲力竭。所以这实际上大约是三分之一，这是一个相当高的数字。同样，我认为我们倾向于认为无聊或“无聊症”是某些特定工作中典型的情况。但事实上，它可能发生在所有工作中，甚至可能发生在专业工作中，在那里你可能正在做表面上看起来相当具有挑战性和有趣的事情，比如法律，但你可能只是因为做了15、20年而感到无聊，它不再让你伸展和挑战，你也不再成长了。你知道，所以我想这可能发生在任何职业、任何年龄、任何角色中，真的。
What is the impact of boreout on workers' physical and mental health? I know you just mentioned exhaustion, Dr. Parker. Are there other characteristics that are emblematic of boreout? I think there are a lot of outcomes. And if I can just stick with the mental health outcomes, first of all. And I guess actually, Dr. Hadju, I'm not sure if you're, I'm sure you're very familiar with this case, but I first became aware of this concept of boreout as opposed to boredom by learning about a French guy, actually, that took his employer to court because of borout, not burnout.
“无聊症”对员工的身心健康有什么影响？帕克博士，我知道你刚才提到了精疲力竭。还有其他象征“无聊症”的特征吗？我认为有很多结果。如果我可以先谈谈心理健康的结果。我想实际上，哈乔博士，我不确定你是否，我相信你非常熟悉这个案例，但我第一次意识到“无聊症”而不是无聊这个概念，是通过了解一个法国人，他实际上因为“无聊症”而不是倦怠把他的雇主告上了法庭。
And that specific case, it was a few years ago now, but it was a guy that felt that he had lost a client and therefore his manager was not giving him any interesting or meaningful work to do. So he literally would go to work and it sort of push pencils around, but he sort of had to stay at work. And that went on for four years. And ultimately, that really affected his mental health, as you would expect, right? Because he's not doing anything meaningful and feeling useless and all of these sorts of things. And he was actually successful in his case. he was awarded about 40,000 euros,
那个具体的案例，虽然是几年前的事了，但那个人觉得他失去了一个客户，因此他的经理没有给他任何有趣或有意义的工作做。所以他实际上每天去上班，只是在推铅笔，但他不得不待在工作岗位上。这种情况持续了四年。最终，正如你所预料的那样，这真的影响了他的心理健康，对吧？因为他没有做任何有意义的事情，感到毫无用处，诸如此类。而且他的诉讼实际上成功了。他获得了大约4万欧元的赔偿，
and because it was found that the employer had not given him sufficiently meaningful work and that that had a consequence for his well-being, a mental well-being, and that that was something his employer should have done differently. So mental health is a really important one. And I think those of us who are sort of perhaps the more burnt out, end of the spectrum, which I suspect is many people, well, we know, actually, it's many people. It's, you know, we sometimes think, oh, wouldn't it be great to have a boring job? You know, wouldn't that be great?
因为法院发现雇主没有给他提供足够有意义的工作，这对他个人的幸福感、心理健康产生了后果，而这是他的雇主本应该做得不同的地方。所以心理健康是一个非常重要的问题。我认为我们中那些可能处于倦怠光谱末端的人，我怀疑是很多人，好吧，我们知道，实际上，是很多人。你知道，我们有时会想，拥有一份无聊的工作不是很好吗？你知道，那不是很好吗？
But of course, you know, that's probably good for an hour or so, you know, and in fact, is a nice little relief to have some somewhat boring tasks. But, you know, chronically for a long time, it is a real mental drain. And so I'm sure that Dr. Hajj can talk about other. effects and I'm happy to as well. But I did just really want to reiterate that it is a very aversive mental state and it can harm people psychologically. Yeah, if I can pick up on that. Indeed, and kind of relating to the question of how boredom or borough is different from burnout, actually they can manifest in similar ways. So there is this lack of energy, even pervasive fatigue
但当然，你知道，那可能对一个小时左右的时间来说是好的，你知道，事实上，有一些稍微无聊的任务是一种很好的解脱。但是，你知道，长期持续下去，这确实是一种真正的精神消耗。所以我相信哈乔博士可以谈谈其他影响，我也很乐意谈谈。但我确实想重申，这是一种非常令人厌恶的精神状态，它会从心理上伤害人们。是的，如果我可以接着说。确实，关于无聊或“无聊症”与倦怠有何不同的问题，实际上它们可以以相似的方式表现出来。所以存在这种缺乏能量的情况，甚至是普遍的疲劳，
that goes along with these kinds of states when they persist. And also there are symptoms of stress. So again, you might not think that bored and being bored is stressful. It's rather we think that it's antithetical to stress because, again, because we think that these are people who don't have enough things to do. So hence they cannot be stressed out. But again, this is not true. We found in research that the more people report boredom,
当这些状态持续存在时，就会伴随而来。而且还有压力的症状。所以同样，你可能不会认为无聊和感到无聊是有压力的。相反，我们认为它与压力是对立的，因为，同样，因为我们认为这些人没有足够的事情做。因此，他们不可能感到压力。但同样，这不是真的。我们在研究中发现，人们报告的无聊感越多，
the more they also report stress symptoms, they report poorer workability, they report poorer self-rated health. We also did a study. These were workers in a municipality in Finland. We asked how often they felt bored at work, and then we had them wear heart rate model. for three days.
他们报告的压力症状也越多，他们报告的工作能力越差，他们报告的自我评估健康状况越差。我们还做了一项研究。这些是芬兰一个城市的员工。我们询问他们工作中感到无聊的频率，然后让他们佩戴心率监测器
And we actually found that the more often people reported being bored at work, the lower their heart rate variability was, which is indicative of poor recovery and this kind of persistent strain. And it's a physical, physiological symptom. So it's not just psychological outcomes, but we have also found physiological outcomes that indicate this kind of severe stress reaction. Yeah.
三天。我们实际上发现，人们报告在工作中感到无聊的频率越高，他们的心率变异性就越低，这表明恢复能力差和这种持续的压力。这是一种身体上的、生理上的症状。所以这不仅仅是心理上的结果，我们还发现了表明这种严重压力反应的生理结果。是的。
So there are similarities in this sense in how also burnout manifests. BOROT can also have the similar manifestations that are harmful for both mental and physical health. And I think also harmful for the organization insofar as, you know, in the end, it's a very demotivating state to feel chronically bored. And so people are disengaged, checked out. Withdrawal is a common response. So that means being absent, not putting all your energy and effort into your job when there are things to do.
所以在这个意义上，倦怠的表现方式也有相似之处。“无聊症”也可能有类似的表现，对心理和身体健康都有害。而且我认为对组织也有害，因为最终，长期感到无聊是一种非常令人丧失动力的状态。所以人们会脱离工作，心不在焉。退缩是一种常见的反应。这意味着缺勤，当有事情要做时，没有把所有的精力和努力投入到工作中。
And even leaving and exiting and turning over from the organisation. So performance is affected as well. And that's really important from that employee perspective. And I often will talk about what you're also doing as an employer is you're really wasting people's talent because people are usually bored because they're not using their skills, developing their skills. And people are an incredibly important resource that it really means you're not actually using and developing and deploying in an optimal way. So that's also important from that perspective. Well, let me ask, is there a way to design jobs better to prevent burnout? And are some jobs just intrinsically less engaging?
甚至离开、退出和从组织中流失。所以绩效也会受到影响。从员工的角度来看，这真的很重要。我经常谈论的是，作为雇主，你实际上是在浪费人才，因为人们通常感到无聊是因为他们没有使用自己的技能，没有发展自己的技能。而人是一种极其重要的资源，这意味着你实际上并没有以最佳方式使用、发展和部署他们。所以从这个角度来看，这也是很重要的。那么，请问，有没有办法更好地设计工作来防止倦怠？有些工作是否本质上就不那么引人入胜？
Can any job be designed or redesigned to make it more engaging? Absolutely. And I guess this is this area of work redesign. And I guess one thing to say is I would normally talk about it from this perspective of creating better work, creating good work. for people and I use a particular model that's been published, so it's an evidence-based model of work design, the smart model. And just very quickly, that sort of is a synthesis, I guess, of decades of research around what is it that makes for healthy, meaningful, motivating work.
任何工作都可以通过设计或重新设计来使其更具吸引力吗？绝对可以。我想这就是工作再设计领域。我想说的一点是，我通常会从创造更好的工作、为人们创造好工作的角度来谈论它，我使用了一个已经发表的特定模型，即基于证据的工作设计模型——SMART模型。简单来说，这大概是几十年来关于什么造就了健康、有意义、激励人心的工作的研究的综合。
The first letter is actually stimulating. And this is about having work that has variety, where you use your skills, where you develop your skills, where you're learning, where you're growing, where you have challenge. There's a little bit of challenge is good in jobs. And of course, what we're talking about here with bored them and bore out is almost the opposite of stimulating work. So, and actually, whenever I present this, and there's other parts of the model, mastery, autonomy, relational aspects of work and then demands is that T is tolerable demands.
第一个字母实际上是“刺激性”（Stimulating）。这是关于拥有多样化的工作，使用你的技能，发展你的技能，学习，成长，拥有挑战。工作中有一点挑战是好的。当然，我们在这里谈论的无聊和“无聊症”几乎是刺激性工作的对立面。所以，实际上，每当我展示这个模型时，还有模型的其他部分，掌握感、自主权、工作的关系方面，然后是要求，那个T是“可承受的要求”（Tolerable demands）。
But whenever I present the smart model to leaders, I always get this question, oh, but not everyone wants stimulating work. I know people who, you know, but actually it's really about what is stimulating for you. And I think also just to pick up on one of your other points about is some work sort of inherently boring, I think you can compensate for that factor a little bit through allowing people to craft the work. But you can also redesign the work completely. And I guess that's where a lot of our research has been done.
但每当我向领导者展示SMART模型时，我总是会遇到这个问题，哦，但并不是每个人都想要刺激性的工作。我知道有些人，你知道，但实际上这真的是关于什么对你来说是刺激性的。而且我认为，仅仅谈论你的另一个观点，即某些工作是否本质上是无聊的，我认为你可以通过允许人们进行“工作重塑”（job crafting）来稍微补偿那个因素。但你也可以完全重新设计工作。我想这就是我们很多研究的重点。
You know, for example, the classic would be, you know, if you think about a traditional sort of assembly line where people are doing a very routine thing, many, many times a day, you know, you can actually make that job broader. You can actually give people more autonomy, create perhaps a self-managing team. And these sorts of experiments have been done in many, many, many. countries around the world and shown really quite significant positive effects for workers and for the company. So you can certainly redesign the work to make it less boring. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk more with Dr. Harjou and Dr. Parker about how to redesign work to make
你知道，例如，经典的例子是，如果你想到传统的装配线，人们每天做很多次非常常规的事情，你知道，你实际上可以让那份工作更广泛。你实际上可以给人们更多的自主权，也许创建一个自我管理的团队。这些实验已经在世界上的许多许多国家进行过，并显示出对工人和公司确实有相当显著的积极影响。所以你当然可以重新设计工作，使其不那么无聊。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与哈乔博士和帕克博士更多地讨论如何重新设计工作以使其
it more engaging. Well, speaking of redesign, who is the best person to design a job? Is it the manager who's going to be overseeing the employee, the employee, him or herself, the human resources department, or do you just need, you know, I.O. Psychologists everywhere. How do we get rid of bore out? Yeah, look, I would always say work design is a multi-party responsibility. I don't think that it's the responsibility of any single group. You get the best outcomes when actually all of those groups that you mentioned are involved. You know, job crafting is this idea that individual themselves can make their work better. And that is to be encouraged.
更具吸引力。说到重新设计，谁是设计工作的最佳人选？是即将监督员工的经理，员工本人，人力资源部门，还是你只需要，你知道，到处都是工业与组织心理学家。我们如何摆脱“无聊症”？是的，看，我总是说工作设计是多方责任。我不认为这是任何单一团体的责任。当你提到的所有这些团体都参与进来时，你会得到最好的结果。你知道，“工作重塑”是一个想法，即个人自己可以让他们的工作变得更好。这是值得鼓励的。
But you mentioned Amazon workers. In many cases, it wouldn't matter how much crafting some of those workers did. The work design is pretty horrific. You know, they're intensely monitored with wristbands or whatever. Their movements are tightly controlled. You know, they can't even get to the bathroom half the time. So you could encourage those guys to craft. as much as they like, but they're going to be very, very constrained.
但你提到了亚马逊的员工。在许多情况下，那些员工进行多少重塑都无济于事。工作设计相当可怕。你知道，他们被腕带或其他东西严密监控。他们的动作受到严格控制。你知道，他们甚至有一半时间连厕所都去不了。所以你可以鼓励那些人尽可能多地进行重塑，但他们会受到非常、非常大的限制。
So in that case, the redesign has to come from the leaders, and probably in all honesty, the leaders will not have enough power. It would have to come from even higher level people, the CEO or whatever, who really want to do things differently. But a lot of the work redesign that we've done, and we do it in contexts like aged care or public sector, all different contexts. You know, we really encourage its employees,
所以在那情况下，重新设计必须来自领导者，而且老实说，领导者可能没有足够的权力。它必须来自更高层的人，CEO或其他什么人，他们真的想以不同的方式做事。但我们所做的大部分工作重新设计，我们是在老年护理或公共部门等背景下进行的，所有不同的背景。你知道，我们真的鼓励员工，
can play their part, the leaders have got to play a part. HR is important, often production managers or what other managers are critical as well. So it's a multi-party approach is when you get the best result. If I cannot just add to that because Dr. Parker, you mentioned job crafting. I think that the best way to get rid of borrout is to prevent it because if people are bored. So if it's a symptom already in the organization, so if it's not just one person, but if it's more widespread. We've also done studies on this and found that when people are bored out, they actually craft their jobs less, not more. So that's when you are already kind of disengaged. You're not motivated. This is not the time to ask people to just craft their
可以发挥他们的作用，领导者必须发挥作用。人力资源很重要，通常生产经理或其他经理也很关键。所以多方参与的方法才能得到最好的结果。如果我能补充一点，因为帕克博士，你提到了“工作重塑”。我认为摆脱“无聊症”的最好方法是预防它，因为如果人们感到无聊。所以如果这已经是组织中的一种症状，所以如果不仅仅是一个人，而是更广泛的现象。我们也对此进行了研究，发现当人们患上“无聊症”时，他们实际上重塑工作的次数更少，而不是更多。所以当你已经处于那种脱离状态时。你没有动力。这不是要求人们去重塑他们的
jobs to be more meaningful, whatever, that's actually kind of grotesque. If we think that, that, you know, first there is this circumstance where people get chronically bored and then we just kind of place the responsibility to the individual. That's not what we should be endorsing at all. Rather, it's better to prevent boredom from becoming this kind of systemic experience at the workplace and indeed by designing good healthy jobs is a good place to start. But then because boredom is, it's a very subjective experience. I mean, it signals this lack of meaning, which is different for any individual. I mean, what is meaningful for me might not be meaningful for you and so on.
工作以使其更有意义等等的时候，那实际上有点荒谬。如果我们认为，你知道，首先存在这种人们变得长期无聊的情况，然后我们只是把责任推给个人。这根本不是我们应该支持的。相反，最好防止无聊成为工作场所的一种系统性体验，确实，通过设计好的、健康的工作是一个很好的起点。但因为无聊是一种非常主观的体验。我的意思是，它预示着这种意义的缺失，这对每个人来说都是不同的。我的意思是，对我来说有意义的事情对你来说可能没有意义，等等。
So then for that, it's also good to give some space for people to influence their own work design by crafting their jobs, for example, or adding some bits of meaning in there, bits of challenge, whatever. It is that is motivating to that individual, but indeed it's better to act before problems such as borrower out arise. And if I can just build off that of Dr. Hajjou's point there, even if the work design is led by leaders or managers, it's absolutely vital that the workers themselves are involved or represented because they are ultimately the experts in the work. They spend all of their time doing that work. And so I think the worst sort of work design cases are the ones where they are just done to their employees and the employees are not involved in the process.
所以对于这一点，给人们一些空间通过例如重塑他们的工作，或者在其中添加一些意义、一些挑战，无论是什么，来影响他们自己的工作设计也是很好的。这对那个个人来说是激励性的，但确实最好在“无聊症”等问题出现之前采取行动。如果我能基于哈乔博士的观点，即使工作设计是由领导者或经理主导的，员工本人参与或代表参与也绝对至关重要，因为他们最终是工作的专家。他们花费所有时间做那项工作。所以我认为最糟糕的工作设计案例是那些只是强加给员工，而员工没有参与过程的案例。
So even if it is led from the top, I would always encourage really good systems of workers getting involved or represented at the very least. So I want to ask, there's been a lot more remote work as a result of the COVID epidemic, and that's even continued now that the epidemic is passed. Has this resulted in less bore out because workers were given more trust and the ability to structure their jobs? Yeah, actually my colleagues in Finland have done some research on this and with any trend I think in the work life at the moment, it's kind of a double edged sword in the sense that there are some employees that can really benefit and in terms of their motivation and engagement for them remote work can be hugely beneficial and motivating. stimulating because it then helps them to do their jobs better, but maybe also just organize their lives a bit better as well. But then there are also those employees who suffer, for whom this is not a preference. So they suffer from the isolation. These are typically people to whom the social environment of the workplace is really important.
所以即使它是从上层领导的，我总是鼓励建立真正好的员工参与或代表参与的系统。所以我想问，由于新冠疫情，远程工作多了很多，即使疫情过去，这种情况仍在继续。这是否导致了更少的“无聊症”，因为员工被赋予了更多的信任和结构化工作的能力？是的，实际上我在芬兰的同事对此做了一些研究，我认为目前工作生活中的任何趋势都是一把双刃剑，因为有些员工确实可以受益，在他们的动力和参与度方面，对他们来说，远程工作可能非常有益且具有激励性。
So for those people, it is not very stimulating to work at home and just meet people via Zoom or whatever other technology there is. So again, it's somewhat individual. And of course, it's also a matter of whether it's chosen, if it's a choice that employees can themselves make or whether it's kind of a forced. arrangement that they have to adapt to. So it's a bit different depending on the situation. But during COVID when it was forced for many people,
刺激性，因为它有助于他们更好地完成工作，但也可能只是更好地组织他们的生活。但也有那些受苦的员工，对他们来说这不是一种偏好。所以他们遭受孤立。这些人通常是那些认为工作场所的社会环境非常重要的人。
there have been these kinds of findings that for many employees it was also a boring situation to be at home alone. Yeah. And I think sometimes, and I remember even feeling this a little bit, you know, that it's sort of invoked a sense of meaningless. like you couldn't start, you sort of start thinking, what is this all for, when you don't have the opportunity to connect with the people who benefit from your work, whether it's students as professors or, you know, other sorts of clients or whatever.
所以对这些人来说，在家工作并通过Zoom或任何其他技术与人见面并不是很刺激。所以同样，这在某种程度上是个人的。当然，这还取决于这是否是选择，如果这是员工自己可以做出的选择，还是他们必须适应的一种强制性安排。所以根据情况，情况有点不同。但在新冠疫情期间，当对许多人来说它是强制性的时，
And so you're right that that disconnection for some people can sort of engender a sense of meaninglessness and boredom, yeah. I was going to say the other thing I think is that if you have got a board, and disengaged workforce, you probably wouldn't want them working from home either. Because, I mean, a lot of the benefits of working from home from a sort of employer productivity perspective are about it's more motivating to work at home and people are likely to work harder, perhaps put some of their commuting time into their work, you know, and because you're signalling trust and so on, you know, they want to put in effort and they want to respect that flexibility that they've
有这样的发现，对许多员工来说，独自在家也是一种无聊的情况。是的。而且我认为有时，我记得甚至有一点这种感觉，你知道，它引发了一种无意义感。就像你无法开始，你开始思考，当没有机会与从你的工作中受益的人联系时，这一切是为了什么，无论是作为教授的学生，还是，你知道，其他类型的客户或其他什么。
got, if you've got a really disengaged board workforce, you know, actually having them all working at home probably wouldn't be great because I suspect they, you know, they're disengaged and bored. They're not necessarily going to be very productive at home either. Well, let me bring up the 800-pound gorilla in our lives today, which is, of course, artificial intelligence. On balance, do we know is AI making our jobs more boring and tedious, or is it giving us more room to be stimulated because it's taking over a lot of the dull work? How much does it depend on the individual job? The bottom line is it can go in either direction. And it's not so much about role or occupation.
所以你是对的，那种脱节对某些人来说可能会产生一种无意义感和无聊感，是的。我本来想说，我认为另一件事是，如果你有一个无聊且脱离工作的员工队伍，你可能也不希望他们在家工作。因为，我的意思是，从雇主生产力的角度来看，在家工作的好处很多在于在家工作更有动力，人们更有可能更努力地工作，也许把一些通勤时间投入到工作中，你知道，而且因为你在传递信任等等，你知道，他们想要投入努力，他们想要尊重他们
I think it's about the choices that are made about their technology and how it's designed and implemented. So let me unpack that a little bit more. So, you know, on the positive side, you've got AI taking up, doing the dull, dirty and dangerous work. You know, that's what technology is supposedly good at. And we're certainly seeing evidence of that, right? You know, routine administrative tasks, record keeping, all the things that we find a bit boring. In theory, AI, this is what AI is really good at. So that's the positive side.
得到的灵活性，如果你有一个非常脱离、无聊的员工队伍，你知道，实际上让他们都在家工作可能不会很好，因为我怀疑他们，你知道，他们脱离且无聊。他们在家里也不一定会有很高的生产力。好吧，让我提出今天我们生活中那个800磅重的大猩猩，当然就是人工智能。总的来说，我们知道人工智能是让我们的工作变得更无聊、更乏味，还是因为它接管了许多枯燥的工作而给了我们更多被刺激的空间？这在多大程度上取决于个人的工作？底线是它可以向任何方向发展。这与其说是关于角色或职业。
But I think what we're also seeing are, you know, So on the one hand, we're seeing things like people cognitively offloading their tasks and that having some consequences for their growth, their skills, their learning, maybe not immediate consequences, but longer term consequences. So I think there's a little bit of a sense in which some people may be slightly deskilling themselves almost through overusing AI and sort of using it too much and becoming too dependent on it. I think another big trend that we're going to see more and more, and we're already seeing, is that roles are shifting from active roles to oversight roles. So let's go to the pilot.
我认为这是关于对技术做出的选择以及它是如何设计和实施的。所以让我再多拆解一下。所以，你知道，在积极的一面，你有AI承担、做枯燥、肮脏和危险的工作。你知道，这就是技术被认为擅长的地方。我们当然看到了这方面的证据，对吧？你知道，常规的行政任务、记录保存，所有我们觉得有点无聊的事情。理论上，AI，这就是AI真正擅长的地方。所以这是积极的一面。
I mean, we're talking automation, not necessarily AI, but we're just going to see more and more of this. You know, with the introduction of autopilot in planes, it got to a situation where pilots were never flying the plane. Okay, great, until something goes wrong with autopilot, and then they can't remember how to fly the plane. And there were a few very high-profile accidents where pilots effectively couldn't fly the plane. So, you know, for all sorts of reasons now, pilots are mandated to fly the plane at least a certain amount of time, and they have simulations and they have things like that that keep those skills out and so on. So, the role turned from an active flying role to an oversight role, a monitoring of another system
但我认为我们还看到的是，你知道，所以一方面，我们看到人们在认知上卸载他们的任务，这会对他们的成长、技能、学习产生一些后果，也许不是直接的后果，而是长期的后果。所以我认为在某种程度上，有些人可能通过过度使用AI，使用得太多并变得过于依赖它，几乎是在轻微地使自己技能退化。我认为我们将看到越来越多的另一个大趋势，而且我们已经看到了，角色正在从主动角色转变为监督角色。所以让我们去看看飞行员。
doing the role. And that's going to happen more and more with AI. The AI systems are making the decisions, just reading today about some loan consultants in a bank. You know, they're not making the decisions anymore about whether clients will get a loan. The AI system is making that decision. And the humans are just overseeing that, hopefully. And actually, they're not always. And these can be more boring roles. They have less autonomy. They're not using their skills and judgment in the same way anymore. So I think that these more passive monitoring oversight type roles are going to grow with AI. And it's going to be sort of interesting to see, are we going to have the same problem that we historically had with pilots, where people monitor,
我的意思是，我们谈论的是自动化，不一定是AI，但我们只会看到越来越多的这种情况。你知道，随着飞机上自动驾驶仪的引入，情况变成了飞行员从不驾驶飞机。好吧，很好，直到自动驾驶仪出了问题，然后他们不记得怎么驾驶飞机了。发生了一些非常引人注目的事故，飞行员实际上无法驾驶飞机。所以，你知道，现在出于各种原因，飞行员被强制要求至少在一定时间内驾驶飞机，他们有模拟器，他们有保持这些技能的东西等等。所以，角色从主动飞行角色转变为监督角色，对另一个系统进行监控
these systems, just lose the skills and knowledge that they need to actually do that effectively. So I think it can go either way, but we've got to be very thoughtful as the developers of tech and as the implementation, the people implementing AI about how we do that and making sure that we are continuing to keep that stimulating work where people are learning and growing and not just watching. And this is probably more for the white-collar professional jobs that can also happen or is happening, is that AI replaces parts of those jobs. So it augments those jobs. It doesn't replace entire jobs, but parts of those jobs.
执行该角色。这种情况会随着AI越来越多地发生。AI系统正在做出决定，刚才读到关于银行里的一些贷款顾问。你知道，他们不再决定客户是否能获得贷款。AI系统正在做出那个决定。而人类只是在监督它，希望如此。实际上，他们并不总是这样。这些可能是更无聊的角色。他们自主权更少。他们不再以同样的方式使用他们的技能和判断力。所以我认为这些更被动的监控监督型角色会随着AI而增长。看看我们是否会遇到我们历史上飞行员遇到的同样问题，即人们监控，
And it may be that those parts that are replaced by AI are actually parts that people very much like to do. So there's been studies on sales jobs. sales professions where customer interface is almost completely handled by bots now. So the salespeople, they don't actually encounter clients, at least not as much as they used to. And this is also, I mean, at least based on, I've talked to many, many salespeople in my research. And this is something that most salespeople actually very much love, you know, interacting with clients, talking to them, meeting them, negotiating, all that jazz. And then they don't have this anymore.
这些系统，只是失去了他们实际有效执行所需的技能和知识。所以我认为它可以向任何方向发展，但作为技术的开发者和实施者，实施AI的人，我们必须非常深思熟虑地考虑我们如何做到这一点，并确保我们继续保持那种人们在学习和成长而不仅仅是观看的刺激性工作。这可能更多是针对白领专业工作，但也可能发生或正在发生，即AI取代了这些工作的一部分。所以它增强了这些工作。它没有取代整个工作，而是取代了这些工作的一部分。
So what is left? So, I mean, this kind of not necessarily de-skilling as such, but just this narrowing down of the scope of many jobs. That is also something that needs to be, you know, when organizations adopt these technology is it's and I'm sure Dr. Parker is the expert on this, but that they have to be very aware on how, what's the impact on people's jobs and motivation and what are the implications for work design. So I want to ask how BORO out looks at different career stages. You know, there are some types of problems that are more common around young people at the beginning of their
而且可能被AI取代的那些部分实际上是人们非常喜欢做的部分。所以已经有关于销售工作的研究。销售职业，客户界面现在几乎完全由机器人处理。所以销售人员，他们实际上并没有遇到客户，至少不像以前那样多了。这也是，我的意思是，至少基于，我在研究中与许多许多销售人员交谈过。这是大多数销售人员实际上非常喜欢的事情，你知道，与客户互动、交谈、见面、谈判，所有这些爵士乐。然后他们不再有这个了。
career versus mid-career or late-career workers? Yeah, I think, and again, it's, of course, quite individual, and age is probably just one factor. But I think I certainly, you know, has someone who's taught lots of MBA students, you know, you see those sort of 35-year-olds mid-career who are finding that they are not stretching themselves in their work anymore. So, you know, they've gone through uni, they've done well, they've got promoted, that, you know, but they just sort of bored. Maybe they're even 45, but that sort of rain,
那么剩下的是什么？所以，我的意思是，这种不一定是技能退化，而只是许多工作范围的缩小。这也是需要被，你知道，当组织采用这些技术时，这是，我相信帕克博士是这方面的专家，但他们必须非常清楚这对人们的工作和动力有什么影响，以及对工作设计有什么影响。所以我想问“无聊症”在不同的职业阶段看起来是什么样的。你知道，有些类型的问题在年轻人职业生涯开始时更常见，
you know, they still got quite a long time ahead of them and they're looking for that new growth. And I guess that's why they choose to do an MBA. So you see that sort of boredom. And then I think in young people, you know, it can be all the things that we've talked about,
与职业中期或职业后期员工相比？是的，我认为，同样，这当然是非常个人的，年龄可能只是一个因素。但我认为我当然，你知道，作为一个教过很多MBA学生的人，你知道，你看到那些35岁左右处于职业中期的人，他们发现他们不再在工作中伸展自己。所以，你知道，他们完成了大学学业，他们表现得很好，他们得到了晋升，那，你知道，但他们只是有点无聊。也许他们甚至45岁了，但那种范围，
just not very interesting work. I think there is a study that Adam Grant and colleagues did a long time ago, which showed that young people, people sometimes can put up with boring work or work that's not very well designed a bit better in the sense of they're doing it because it's part of the journey that they're on with their career and they know it's a temporary state. And I think an example of that might be as a young lawyer, it's pretty boring perhaps for the first couple of years, but you sort of know that it's a trajectory that you just got to get through. So that's perhaps something also to take into account
你知道，他们前面还有很长的时间，他们正在寻找新的成长。我想这就是他们选择攻读MBA的原因。所以你看到了那种无聊。然后我认为在年轻人身上，你知道，它可以是我们谈论的所有事情，
It's a little bit like, yes, the meaning of the boredom might shift at different stages in your life. And, you know, maybe if you're a young parent with small children, you crave a little bit of boredom because you're so exhausted from your family life, you know. So I think, so I guess, I guess, you know, stages of career can make a difference sort of in how you interpret that stimulating work and how much of an issue it is for you. What can also change is what is stimulating work for you in those different stages of career. We know from early career workers that often there can also be this mismatch of expectations. I mean, highly educated early career workers can come.
只是工作不太有趣。我认为亚当·格兰特（Adam Grant）和同事很久以前做过一项研究，表明年轻人，人们有时可以更好地忍受无聊的工作或设计得不是很好的工作，因为他们这样做是因为这是他们职业生涯旅程的一部分，他们知道这是一种暂时的状态。我想这方面的一个例子可能是作为一名年轻律师，前几年可能相当无聊，但你某种程度上知道这是一条你必须经历的轨迹。所以这也许也是需要考虑的事情。
They're eager to really develop their skills, to show the world what they have. and they are eager to get ahead. This might not happen as rapidly as they might sometimes like or maybe they have to do some searching first to find a place in an organization. I mean, we do find in our research that younger employees tend to report more boredom. So this might be the reason that they're not necessarily established enough yet to get those challenging tasks in organizations. And there might be this kind of mismatch of what they would like to do,
他们渴望真正发展自己的技能，向世界展示自己的能力，也渴望取得进步。但这可能不会像他们有时希望的那样迅速，或者他们可能必须先进行一番探索，才能在组织中找到一席之地。我的意思是，我们的研究确实发现，年轻员工往往报告说感到更无聊。所以这可能是因为他们还没有足够成熟，无法在组织中承担那些具有挑战性的任务。而且，他们想做的事情与他们在这个职业阶段被分配的任务之间，可能存在某种错位，
but the kinds of tasks that they're given at that career point. So that could be one explanation. Also, it might also be that younger employees haven't yet kind of figured out what it is that they actually want to do. They might be directed by, you know, whatever they learn in a business company school, what they should be doing and, you know, parents, whoever. You know, so they were in this stage where they're kind of figuring stuff out. So that may play a role there as well, whereas indeed later it might be more about just
所以这可能是一个解释。此外，这也可能是因为年轻员工还没有真正弄清楚自己到底想做什么。他们可能会受到商学院学到的东西、他们应该做什么的指导，或者受到父母或其他人的影响。你知道，所以他们正处于一个正在摸索事情的阶段。因此，这在其中也可能起到了一定的作用，而事实上，在以后的阶段，这可能更多地是关于
meaning, you know, that people kind of, when they reach a certain point in their careers, but also lives, they might kind of rethink what's meaningful. They might want to do more meaningful things because they've already kind of seen and done some things become established in a career and they might yearn through more meaning, kind of having more of an impact, more meaningful impact in the world rather than just making a living.
意义，你知道，当人们在职业生涯和生活中达到某个阶段时，他们可能会重新思考什么是更有意义的。他们可能想做更有意义的事情，因为他们已经见识过并做过一些事情，在职业生涯中站稳了脚跟，他们可能会渴望更多的意义，渴望在世界上产生更大的影响，更有意义的影响，而不仅仅是为了谋生。
One thing we haven't talked so much about is the importance of stimulating, interesting, meaningful work from a growth perspective and a learning perspective. And, you know, if we look into the future and ask that question, what are this most important skills in an AI world? You know, probably the most important meta skill is learning, you know, and the ability to adapt and change and upskill and re-skill as work evolves and changes. But actually, if we've got boring, unstimulating work, we're really cutting off that growth and learning opportunity. So I just think that is a really important thing we need to.
我们还没有谈论太多的一点是，从成长和学习的角度来看，刺激性、有趣且有意义的工作的重要性。而且，你知道，如果我们展望未来并提出这个问题：在人工智能时代，最重要的技能是什么？你知道，可能最重要的元技能就是学习，以及随着工作的演变和变化，适应、改变、提升技能和重新学习的能力。但实际上，如果我们从事的是枯燥、缺乏刺激的工作，我们实际上是在切断这种成长和学习的机会。所以我认为这是一个我们必须注意的非常重要的事情。
to be sure that those employers out there creating boring work are aware of. And just to wrap up, I want to ask you both, what are you working on now? I mean, what are the big questions you have studies ongoing? What are you still trying to figure out? In terms of research on boredom, I'm currently interested in the work kind of leisure interface and things like whether people who are bored at work, do they then, kind of try to find more meaningful engaging things to do during their leisure. So do they kind of orient themselves more to their life outside of work?
要确保那些创造枯燥工作的雇主意识到这一点。最后，我想问你们两位，你们现在在研究什么？我的意思是，你们正在进行的研究中，有哪些重大问题？你们还在试图弄清楚什么？就无聊感的研究而言，我目前对工作与休闲的界面很感兴趣，比如那些在工作中感到无聊的人，是否会在休闲时间尝试寻找更有意义、更吸引人的事情来做？也就是说，他们是否会更多地将自己定位在工作之外的生活中？
Or whether people who have this fulfilling things going on outside of their work life, they have great hobbies or whatever challenging pursuits outside of work, does it actually make them choose less stimulating, demanding jobs because this is not what they want to be investing in. So this kind of interplay, these dynamics, I'm interested in that right now. And I'm also interested in looking at boredom at work and kind of ethics, ethical behaviors and ethics in organization as well. Dr. Parker, what about you? What are you up to?
或者，那些在工作之外有充实生活的人，他们有很棒的爱好或工作之外的其他挑战性追求，这是否实际上让他们选择了刺激性较小、要求较低的工作，因为这不是他们想要投入精力的领域。所以这种相互作用，这些动态，是我现在感兴趣的。我也对研究工作中的无聊感以及组织中的道德、道德行为和伦理感兴趣。帕克博士，你呢？你在忙什么？
Well, we are very lucky to have recently received an award for a very large research center on, it's called Quality Work in a Digital Age. And it's exactly in the context of your earlier question, Kim, about, you know, what is all this, what does it mean from an AI perspective for work? But we have a very diverse group of scholars from, you know, artificial intelligence professors to computer scientists to a competition. to economists, lawyers, psychologists. So we have social researchers and technical researchers and we're really adopting very strongly this socio-technical perspective, which is really to say we've got to stop thinking about AI
嗯，我们非常幸运，最近为一个大型研究中心获得了一笔资助，该中心名为“数字时代的优质工作”。这正是你之前提出的问题的背景，金，关于人工智能对工作意味着什么？但我们有一个非常多元化的学者群体，从人工智能教授到计算机科学家，再到经济学家、律师、心理学家。所以我们有社会研究人员和技术研究人员，我们确实非常坚定地采取这种社会技术视角，也就是说，我们必须停止仅仅从纯粹的技术角度来思考人工智能，
and purely from a very technical point of view and actually look at these sorts of issues that we're talking about, work design, culture, leadership, skills, regulation. And so that's what our centre is all about. We've got seven years. And, yeah, super excited to be sort of embarking on this journey. It's absolutely the right time. Yeah.
而是要真正审视我们正在讨论的这些问题，如工作设计、文化、领导力、技能、监管。这就是我们中心的核心所在。我们有七年的时间。而且，是的，非常兴奋能踏上这段旅程。这绝对是最好的时机。是的。
In fact, we're a bit late, but better late than never. Well, Dr. Harjou, Dr. Parker, I want to thank you both for joining me today. It's been very interesting and stimulating, not boring in the least. Thank you so much for having us. You can read more about Boreout in the September issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology, which you can find online at www.apa.org backslash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
事实上，我们有点晚了，但总比不做好。好吧，哈乔博士，帕克博士，我要感谢你们今天加入我的节目。这非常有趣且具有启发性，一点也不枯燥。非常感谢你们邀请我们。您可以在美国心理学会（APA）的《心理学监测》杂志九月刊上阅读更多关于“职业倦怠”（Boreout）的内容，您可以在线访问 www.apa.org/monitor。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学对话》的往期节目。
And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您喜欢您所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。《心理学对话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。